Every week this mystery box shows up at my
doorstep.
It's one of those subscription boxes, except
instead of dog toys or makeup, it's food from
local farmers.
And I never know exactly what I'm gonna get.
Got some salad greens, asparagus, and red
corn..?
But this wasn't always such an unusual sight.
If you look through old seed catalogues like
these ones, you'll see hundreds of varieties
of corn, with names like "Dibbles' Mammoth,"
"Kendel's Early Giant," and my personal favorite,
"Potter's Excelsior".
But none of these varieties exist anymore.
American farmers used to grow hundreds of
varieties of sweet corn, tomatoes, and other
edible plants.
Today, just a tiny fraction of those varieties
are still around.
So what happened to all these plants?
For most of our time on this planet, humans
have been hunter gatherers.
We ate what was nearby.
This was still true when we invented farming
10,000 years ago, by cultivating wild plants
like Teosinte in Central America and Thorn
Apple in Africa, the Middle East, and Southeast
Asia.
Over thousands of years, farmers bred these
wild ancestors into foods like corn and eggplant,
that we would recognize today.
As humans moved around the world, so did the
seeds and farmers continued to breed different
varieties to adapt them to their new environments.
Which led to a ton of genetic diversity.
Farmers could raise different genetic varieties
of different crops.
If disease or pests killed one type, there
were others to fall back on.
But gradually industrialization and cheap
fossil fuels made us less dependent on what
grew well nearby.
"Food on the move, from distant parts of the
world comes the great variety of foods Americans
demand."
Most farmers switched from growing a variety
of edible plants to a single crop that was
easy to process and ship.
As this model spread beyond the United States,
older varieties of plants and animals disappeared
from farms around the world.
By 1970, 90% of the wheat varieties that had
once been grown in China were gone.
As were 80% of the varieties of maize or corn
that were once grown in Mexico.
By the summer of 1971, more than 85% of the
corn planted in the US was genetically identical.
Crop scientists had bred this new corn so
that it grew without a tassel, making it easier
to harvest.
But because these plants were genetic copies
of one another, that also made them susceptible
to the same deadly fungus, Southern Leaf Corn
Blight.
It took over the US corn crop, costing farmers
and taxpayers millions of dollars.
And the damage would have continued, if it
weren't for a humble little plant called Teosinte.
The wild grass native to Oaxaca, Mexico, and
the common ancestor of the 22,000 known varieties
of corn.
Teosinte includes a gene for resistance to
the same fungus that was devastating the US
corn crop.
Scientists halted the damage by crossbreeding
Teosinte with American corn, but that didn't
totally solve the problem of genetic diversity.
Today, more than 40% of the corn grown in
the US is derived from just six inbred lines.
And seed companies, driven by profit, can
repackage genetic copies of the same seeds
for different prices.
Farmers plant them, thinking that they're
genetically diversifying their fields when
really they're not.
Since the corn crisis in 1971 disease has
ravaged genetically uniform crops of beans,
rice tomatoes, and bananas.
And it's about to get worse.
The plants we eat have spent thousands of
years evolving to grow in specific conditions,
conditions we are changing rapidly by releasing
more and more carbon dioxide into the atmosphere.
We depend on corn, wheat, and rice for more
than 60% of our global calories.
And by 2050, we'll have 2 billion more people
to feed.
But because of climate change, we'll actually
be producing less of all three of these crops.
We're going to need plants that can grow in
radically different conditions and the more
genetic varieties we save, the better protected
we'll be.
There are seed banks all over the world where
scientists, indigenous communities, and farmers
are all preserving older seed varieties.
But thousands have already been lost, which
is why it's so critical to preserve the genetic
diversity we still have.
The weird stuff, like red popcorn.
And the best way to save the seeds that might
save us one day, is to grow them and eat them.